a un-backed war crimes tribunals
rejected and appealed by the last
surviving Comal Rouge leader the court
in Cambodia has upheld the genocide
conviction and life sentence handed to
91 year old who Sampan in 2018. it was
head of stage during the rule of the
come out Rouge when two million people
mostly minority groups were killed when
Florence Louise following the story for
us from Kuala Lumpur Florence is it a
sense that this is the end of this story
that's right this is the second but it's
also the final case to be heard by this
U.N Bank tribunal and cuson Pon he was
initially charged with three others but
one was found unfit to stand trial and
one died before he had the hearing could
commence but he was convicted in 2018
together with nunche who was known as
brother number two in the Khmer Rouge
regime and he this is he's appealing
that conviction now nunche died before
the appeal could be heard but on
Thursday the appeals chamber of the um
tribunal dismissed nearly all the um all
the arguments put forth by Chu sunpon
prosecutors say he was one of the one of
those who was most responsible for the
crimes during that period even though
kuson Pond had sought to portray himself
as a mere figurehead he was the head of
state he was the public face of the
Khmer Rouge regime and he had tried to
argue that he had no real power now the
court was not convinced of the arguments
and they said even though there were
some errors that were found at trial
Stitch it was not enough to overturn
that conviction and so they've affirmed
the life sentence now and practically it
actually makes very little difference
because he's already serving another
life sentence for a conviction handed
down in 2014 also for crimes against
humanity for the forced evacuation of
Phnom Penh Florence this has been going
on for some time with his tribunalers do
people feel that it's actually been
worthwhile
well it's hard to say I mean it's hard
to say this I mean the hearings have
taken 16 years it's cost 330 million
dollars they prosecuted five people
they've only managed to secure three
convictions the first was in 2010 of a
prison Chief who ran the notorious tall
sling prison in Phnom Penh his name was
King Egg and he was known as doik and 14
000 people died in that prison after
being held there and the other two
convictions were of course of um kuson
Pon and also brother number two nonche
so there is a sense that this tribunal
really could have done a lot more it may
have provided a small sense of
accountability but really could have
done more but although from the very
start I think there were concerns that
this tribunal would be in a way
vulnerable to political interference
because of the hybrid nature of the
Court it has foreign judges sitting
together with Cambodian judges and those
concerns proved validated in a way after
hunsen the Prime Minister said that
there should be no more cases After Case
002 which is this case now but having
said that there are also many who feel
that this court provided a space for
National reconciliation because during
those hearings
survivors of the Khmer Rouge regime
relatives of people who died during the
Khmer Rouge regime were able to testify
directly in court and their testimony
has been that they're being kept on
record in a way memorializing the
sufferings of those cambodians so in a
sense I think even though some feel that
this court could have done a lot more
perhaps its Legacy goes beyond the
convictions that it's handed down
Florence thank you very much indeed
Florence Louis talking to us from Kuala
Lumpur